tu étais la 12e journée d'affilée de
rassemblement contre le racisme contre
les méthodes de la politique de la
police américaine marée humaine qui a
défilé pendant des heures autour de la
maison blanche valérie beaudouin
spécialiste de la politique américaine à
la chaire raoul dandurand de liberté et
du québec à montréal bonjour valérie
bonjour comment vous avez vu cette
manifestation d'un point de vue
politique manifestation qui avait lieu
tout près de la maison blanche
et puis c'est bien différent de notre
conversation du week-end dernier parce
qu'on a eu des manifestations politiques
et j'aiderai les manifestation pacifique
partout aux états unis donc vraiment ça
fait du bien aussi de voir pour les
manifestants qui avaient pas des forces
de l'ordre qui étaient aussi présents qu
que lors d'autres manifestations ou
voyez c'est très familial alors je vois
on voit vraiment qu'un mouvement
derrière sa wii avait avant un mouvement
je voudrais quand même derrière aussi de
casseurs de gens qui voulaient peu
l'anarchie dans tout ça mais vraiment
hier on a vu que c'est des gens qui
voulaient des changements politiques qui
avaient des messages très très fort qui
était diffusée est vraiment le fait que
les policiers qui se sont mis en retrait
dans plusieurs villes américaines
ça démontre est contente d'écouter les
manifestants et de palais propose que
non plus je donne un exemple à new york
et une manifestation pacifique n'y avait
toujours un couvre-feu d'imposer non
seulement ne pas imposer le couvre-feu
il ya aussi des inspecteurs de la police
de new york ont décidé après le couvre
feu deux marchés avec les manifestants
donc ça envoie quand même un message
très très fort il ya même des jugements
aussi des tribunaux en qui font en sorte
que les gaz lacrymogènes le lancement de
balles de caoutchouc
c'est interdit à moins que ça vient
vraiment d'en haut donc du service de
police là comme indication un clan donc
on sent quand même qu'un changement
concernant la façon dont on veut que les
manifestations soient gérées depuis la
maison blanche donald trump
réagi mais ça fait quand même deux
longueurs avant qu'il le fasse ouais
quand même en après midi on dirait
qu'une certaine retenue de ne pas tweeté
ne peut rien dire
faudrait que les manifestations étaient
pacifiques alors il n'y avait pas grand
chose non plus à dire de critiques comme
les autres points de vue et qu'il faut
est mentionné au du fait qu'il y avait
des casseurs qui s'infiltrent est et que
la police allait démontrer de la force a
lorsqu'il a simplement dit c'est que la
foule n'était pas aussi grande qu'on
l'avait dit alors qu'il y avait beaucoup
moins de gens qui étaient présents à
washington
alors il ya toujours un peu cette
comparaison en dix ans hier les genres
et pendant dix ans et couteau il y avait
plus de gens dans cette manifestation
qu'a votre assermentation alors il ya
toujours ce petit côté la politique qui
est utilisé pour se piquer d'un côté ou
de l'autre
ça a été sa réaction je me délecte du
côté de dubaï dont l'âme est une
réaction différente à dubaï on quitte
officiellement candidat démocrate à la
présidence depuis ça fait à peine deux
jours je crois de personnes oui oui
exactement parce qu'ils atteignent
nombre de délégués nécessaire lui hier
ce qu'il a fait c'est qu'il a publié un
éditorial dans le los angeles times et
s'est engagé auprès de notre engagement
pour les 100 premiers jours de sa
présidence
s'il est élu il va y avoir une
commission nationale pour vraiment
réévaluer les pratiques policières
il a dit que c'est le racisme et lutter
conte ce n'est pas une affaire
d'afro-américains amène à faire de tous
les américains
comment vous pensez que ça pour ans chez
traduire ce qui se passe actuellement
sur les présidentielles de novembre
écoutez ce que les gens disent dans la
rue ce que les activistes dc oui c'est
beau on ne va pas voter pourtant ranger
dans la plupart c'est ce qu'ils vont
dire mais ils ne veulent pas se faire
prendre pour acquis comme ça a été par
d'autres administrations démocrates
comme ça a été pour d'autres candidats
démocrates henry veulent des promesses
concrètes de joe biden des démocrates
alors c'est pas les votes contre x ont
acquis parce qu'on le sait a eu une
baisse du vote lors de la dernière
élection lorsqu'il était madame piétonne
qui s'est présenté contre dans mon job
une baisse de vote afro américains aux
états unis ce qui est une première en
plusieurs années parce qu'on va être
jour une hausse constante
alors on doit vraiment faire certaines
promesses mais tout ce côté là de
brutalité policière de réformes
ça va être ça du côté des démocrates et
du côté républicain si on se fie à ce
que nous avons choisi comme message ça
va être un message vraiment de la loi et
l'ordre
ce qui avait d'ailleurs présenté comme
message aussi en 2016
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
ya comme un mélange des genres
actuellement chez donald trump parfois
c'est le président américain qui essaie
de gérer la crise
et souvent c'est le candidat républicain
vous avez bien raison parce qu'il ya eu
des moments quand même il faut dire il
rapidement faire quand même ses
sympathies à la famille de georges
fournier dit que ça devait pas avoir lu
à la rue kidrobot message politique
au départ c'est par la suite que ça
s'est gâché et je voudrais que ce qui a
été le point vraiment culminant tout ça
ça a été lorsqu'il présentait ses
résultats
ces chiffres économiques alors en
parlant du chômage elle si je me trompe
pas c'était vendredi et qu'il a parlé de
georgetown en faisant un parallèle
vraiment assez douteux que choqué
beaucoup de gens envoient en présentant
le fait qu'il y avait une création
d'emplois aux états unis et ça devait
être une bonne journée pour giorgio
floyd écoutez ça pas passé et longe
santé le discours politique qui étaient
là pour dire que l'économie vont être
lancés ça va être une bonne année
économique l'année prochaine et georges
tron et les inégalités raciales c'est
quelque chose qui va être pratiquement
du passé avec une économie très forte
aux états unis et c'est pas le message
que les admire qui a pâti s'attendait à
voir de leur prise dans mon sens quand
même un changement de ton dans les
manifestations a beaucoup oui lui passif
et que moins de casse on va suivre bien
sûr l'évolution tous à valérie beaudouin
merci pour vos lumières ce matin merci
bien merci au revoir